the new wave of feminism is I don't want
to lean on a man and also I don't want
to work like that because capitalism is
evil right so I just want to get stuff
from the government why is this
dangerous because these people vote
this is the new voting block that should
terrify everybody at home these young
women they're all over the internet all
over the internet right they've made bad
decisions for their own life they
de-prioritize family they de-prioritize
motherhood and they also de-prioritize
any form of capitalism or hard work they
want your money they're going to vote
for a politician who's going to take
from you to give to them so that they
don't have to have a family structure
they don't have to have any personal
responsibility or accountability they
don't have to work hard they don't have
to do anything but steal your money
[Music]
thank you